foreign
[Music]
author Vlog brother and whatever the
opposite of a mosquito Enthusiast is you
never want to get up close and personal
with mosquitoes unless it's like this a
microscope's distance away
under the lens the mosquito undergoes a
transformation of sorts before it was a
pesky biting insect whose presence was
felt at best through itchy bumps left on
our skin and at worst through a whole
slew of diseases but under the
microscope mosquitoes undergo a
metamorphosis sculpted in Gold the
buzzing body takes on a life of its own
its usual role as Menace lying far
beyond the margins of the screen the
mosquito is beautiful a sentence I never
expected to say and that I assume you
never expected to hear
even the parts that are less elegant
become Charming like their legs they may
look like a Christmas tree that's
collapsed into a pile of Cheeto dust
right now but when you think about the
tiny hooks along their surface that
allow the mosquito to latch onto
surfaces and of the scales that help
repel water so they can walk across
ponds well then you start to realize
you're looking at an incredible feat of
you know feet
and of course there are the wings which
are always an impressive part of nature
to witness in action along the edges you
can see scaly hairs that the insect uses
to process its surroundings mosquito
wings are unique in several ways they're
unusually long and narrow and they flap
at an incredibly High rate even compared
to other insects of their size around
800 times per second to learn How These
Wings work scientists needed to use
high-speed cameras capturing 10 000
frames per second so they could
distinguish each step of that rapid
movement and in the process of flying
the movement of the Wings creates the
buzzing that warns us a mosquito is
nearby it's an infuriating noise when
it's right against your ear but for the
mosquitoes it's a signal an instrument
that guides them toward each other male
and female mosquito will even go so far
as to converge on the same Wing flapping
frequency when they're cording
[Music]
and with that image in mind we've
conjured up a vision of the mosquito
that is both beautiful and romantic
flirting wistfully through Wing flap
patterns all it takes to shatter that
notion is this part the proboscis this
is what allows the mosquito to drink
from us
at first the proboscis looks like a
simple instrument like a very Pokey
straw that connects with our blood
vessels but in reality it is a complex
machine made up of six thin spear-like
structures called stylets two styloids
hold the tissue apart while another pair
act like drill bits digging through our
skin and then a stylet called the labrum
sniffs out blood vessels using receptors
that turn our body's chemistry into a
map and when it does find the vessel the
labrum converts itself into a pipeline
carrying blood to the mosquito the sixth
and last stylet helps the labrum with
its task by injecting mosquito saliva
into our blood vessels this is not just
gross mosquito backwash mosquito saliva
contains enzymes that dilate our blood
vessels and prevent our immune system
from responding
at least that's what the female mosquito
does because all of this work it's not
actually to provide the mosquito's main
meal mosquitoes sustain themselves on
nectar and fruit juices Blood on the
other hand is about the Next Generation
and the eggs that will make them
so male mosquitoes don't consume blood
their proboscis isn't even strong enough
to pierce our skin but female mosquitoes
need blood for reproduction using the
nutrients particularly iron to fuel the
growth of their eggs over her lifetime
the female mosquito may lay around 500
eggs
so if the physical discomfort that
follows a bite is not enough misery for
you rest uneasily in the knowledge that
your blood has fueled the birth of the
next round of mosquitoes that will
plague you and the world
and plague is the obvious word to go
with when it comes to mosquitoes the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention call mosquitoes the world's
deadliest animal because of the
essential role they play in spreading
disease a short list of the mosquitoes
notorious diseases include malaria
Dengue West Nile zika and lymphatic
filariasis the actual organisms
responsible for these diseases include
protists worms and viruses but their
spread is driven by mosquitoes hopping
from person to person to get their blood
and leaving behind an unwanted Memento
of the microcosmos when they leave
malaria for example is the potentially
fatal work of parasitic protists that
belong to the genus plasmodium when an
infected mosquito bites a human the
plasmodium quickly travels to the liver
usually reaching its destination in 20
minutes and then the parasite reproduces
moving through different stages of their
life cycle as they infect red blood
cells when another mosquito comes along
for blood it will end up taking some of
the parasite with it keeping the cycle
going and going and going in 2021 there
were
247 million cases of malaria worldwide
and 619 000 people died from the disease
to try to prevent these deaths humans
have tried many strategies to curb the
mosquito population or their ability to
spread disease
insecticides genetic engineering there
have been a wide range of tools but we
want to end with one that resonates the
most with the microcosmos it would look
kind of like this an array of ciliates
born across the skin of a larva when
scientists have pitted the vorticella a
journey to the microcosmos favorite
Against The larva of certain mosquito
species the mosquitoes have fared quite
poorly
it's not clear why or how but the
mosquito larvae die the vorticella might
prevent them from staying on the surface
of water getting in the way of their
respiration or the vorticella might
Simply Be poisoning the mosquitoes with
chemical secretions of their own and if
only the mosquito weren't a mosquito
perhaps we could sympathize because we
know the plight of a pest attached to
our skin leaving behind misfortunes both
small and deadly but the microcosmos is
the beginning and end of so many
Journeys and even the mighty mosquito
the vector of so many diseases can find
its own wanderings cut short
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us we also want to say
thank you to all the people whose names
you're seeing on the screen right now
those are some of our patreon patrons
and we could not continue to make this
show without them if you'd like to see
more from our master of microscopes
James Weiss you can check out jam and
germs on Instagram and if you'd like to
see more from us there should be a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign